Diese brandneue Folge des Podcast-Ufos wird Ihnen präsentiert von der offiziellen Podcast-Ufo-Telegram-Gruppe. Träte jetzt kostenlos ein und werde Teil der lustigsten Podcast-Community Deutschlands. Das Podcast-Ufo. Jetzt Eintritten unter htps.pl.//t.meich das Wort Kastofo. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcasts Opho mit mir, der Mathis und dir, Florentin Will. Ja, vielen Dank. Es war die erste Werbung. Ich habe mich schon die ganze Zeit gefragt, wann kommt jemand auf die Idee, mal Werbung zu machen? Und warum kommen diese ganzen dusseligen Unternehmen, für die wir die ganze Zeit Werbung machen, nicht mal auf die Idee, einfach ein fucking Intro einzureichen? Stimmt, über das Intro können sie es kostenlos machen. Können sie es kostenlos kriegen. Ja, das war das Intro von der Podcast UFO-Telegram-Gruppe, die immer noch heiter existiert. Ich bin neulich drin, 237.000 Nachrichten in Abwesenheit. Ich glaube, das dauert nicht lange, bis sie irgendwie so ein Selbstmordkult werden oder irgendwie sowas und komplett abdriften und dann irgendwie in der Zeitung steht, dann irgendwie so, die Täter bekannten sich zur Podcast UFO-FO-Telegram-Gruppe und wie so, das wird ein gereimtes Statement, das die Welt so lange nicht vergisst. Ups, ja, wie bei allen, ja, am Ende steht immer ein grosses Ups, Huch, Huch, Oh, Oh, jetzt sehe ich es auch, jetzt, Shit, berühmte letzte Worte, ah, jetzt verstehe ich wovon, warum ihr mich die ganze Zeit davor gewarnt habt. Ja, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Ich finde es clever, tretet gerne der UFO-Telegram-Rufe bei. Auf jeden Fall, ihr könnt glaube ich jetzt noch einen Unterschied machen. Ihr könnt sie jetzt noch auf den rechten Bahn, auf den rechten Weg wieder zurück. Oder über die Klippe stürzen. Also ihr könnt auf jeden Fall eine spannende Rolle spielen in diesem ganzen Prozess. Um ganz kurz mal das Organisatorische abzuprasen.
Die letzte Woche war gespickt mit grossereignissen, die natürlich Wellen geschlagen haben in der Podcast-UV-Community. Die Tour wurde angekündigt, neue Folge kam raus, Pufopedia-Neuer-Content, ja, aber egal was wir machen,, nichts hat auch nur im Ansatz so viel Wellen
geschlagen wie die Frage,
in wie viele Container
passt das Essen, das man
das Leben über isst.
Und wir haben ganze Abhandlungen bekommen, wir haben
Doktorarbeiten bekommen, wir haben mit
verschiedenen Quellen, mit verschiedenen
Leuten aus verschiedenen Fachrichtungen.
Willi ist ein Trottel,
lass dir nicht sagen,
zwölf ist viel näher dran. Also Leute
haben es wirklich auch ernst genommen, wie viele
Aber aus verschiedenen Fachrichtungen. Mir hat jemand geschrieben, Willis ist ein Trottel, lass dir nicht sagen, zwölf ist viel näher dran. Also Leute haben es wirklich auch ernst genommen, wie viele, ich habe mich behauptet, zwölf Container circa an Volumen essen, nimmt ein Mensch zu sich, aber da ist wirklich gar keine Luft mehr in dem Container, das hätte ich noch dabei sagen sollen, nichts. Also nicht Wassermelonen, wie gesagt, nicht die Verpackung zählt, sondern das Volumen, das ist schwierig auszudrücken, aber wenn du Bälle lagerst, geht ja viel Raumflöten, viel Dead Space. Ihr müsst euch dafür, für dieses Szenario, quadratische Wassermelonen ohne Rand, also ohne Rinde vorstellen. Ach, die Rinde zählt nicht. Nee, die isst du ja nicht. Du kannst auch nicht bei einem Hähnchen eine Knochen in den Container schmeißen. Gut, wir haben auf jeden Fall mehrere Antworten bekommen. Und wie gesagt, ich sag zwei, du sagst zwölf. Und es ist natürlich interessant, aus unserer Perspektive zu sehen, wie stark die Antworten auch da so auseinander gehen. Ja eben, aber da haben wir ja auch letzte Forderung, hast du schon angesprochen, es gilt ja das Gesetz der Mitte. Und eigentlich müsste es bei uns beiden, müsste dann ja die logische Antwort sein, ungefähr sechs Container, sieben Container, acht Container und so. Aber wenn jetzt du so ein Trottel warst, so eine schlechte Kackantwort zu geben, dann rüttelst du ja gerade an den Gesetzen der Menschheit. Es stimmt schon. Ich glaube, wir machen es so. Wir stellen alle Antworten und alle, wir haben teilweise wirklich ganze Bachelorarbeiten bekommen, ganze wissenschaftliche Arbeiten, stellen wir alle auf die Puffopedia-Seite dieser Folge und dann sollen die das untereinander ausmachen. Weil jeder hat für sich die komplette Objektivität beansprucht und er sagt, ja, ich habe ja offizielle Daten des Bundesministeriums für Ernährung und voluminöses Essen und der andere sagt, ja, ich bin Physiker, ich rechne euch das aus, kein Problem. Ich glaube, das wird so ein richtiger Wissenschaftsstreit. Ja, und ich will auch von allen, also einer soll bitte diesen Diskurs leiten oder macht, oder nimmt die Sperre in die Hand. Ja, wir brauchen schon ein Komitee, das ist schon klar. Genau, oder, aber einer soll auf jeden Fall auch alle Zahlen nehmen und davon die Mitte nehmen. Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich eine Durchschnittsfrage, die Frage ist, nach welchen Zahlen geht man. Und selbst ist es interessant, weil selbst als es um diese Folge ging mit deinen zehn häufigsten Buchstaben, selbst da habe ich unterschiedliche Listen gefunden. Ja, aber das ist ja empirisch erhebbar, naja. Also wir gucken mal ein paar Antworten an. Ich habe es mal runtergekürzt, nur auf die tatsächlichen Container gefragt, waren diese Normcontainer, diese Containerschiff-Container. Ich sag zwei, du sagst sechs. Zwölf, ich sag. Zwölf. Hendrik schreibt uns und gibt als Antwort einen halben. Ja. Hendrik sagt einen halben. Das habe ich an einem Tag weg, Leute. Hendrik. Aber das ist meine Theorie, Working Theory. Hendricks mit D in diesem Namen sind für mich so Aliens, die versucht haben, Namen anzunehmen und haben so grob, haben so halb hingehört, haben es nicht genau verstanden, haben diesen Namen falsch angenommen und bewegen sich durch die Welt mit weirden Mails und Theorien. Nee, es ist ein Hendrick mit D, hätte man gleich sehen können, von daher würde ich sagen, raus. Könnt ihr allen Spam direkt. Mike schreibt, 38 Jahre für einen Container. Also alle 38 Jahre einen Container weggeputzt. Aber ganz kurz, hätte er nicht auch noch den Dreisatz machen können, um das zumindest auf ein Lebensjahr auszurechnen? Nee, das überlässt er uns. Also sagen wir mal so 2,83 Container. Am Tag. Also schon mal ein guter Unterschied zu Hendrik. Kommen wir zu Jakob, der das Ganze auch ausgerechnet hat, der hat das mit Daten des Bundesamts für Ernährung gemacht und hat dann das voluminös ausgerechnet, der kommt auf 4,4 Container. Also im Leben. Im Leben. Also es steigt und ja, ich bin gespannt, welche Daten noch reinkommen und ich glaube, wir haben einfach mal jede Zahl, die es gibt, irgendwann mal als Antwort bekommen. Also allein da schwankt es zwischen 0,5 und 4,4, was schon ein gutes Schwanken ist auf jeden Fall. Ich habe 22 auch viel bekommen, aber ich habe auch häufig bekommen die Zahl, 22. Und dann gab es anscheinend irgendein Video oder ein Artikel, wo es hieß, ja so viele Leute essen das und da wurde auch eine Antwort gegeben, aber das haben wir uns nicht angeschaut. Das war zu lang, der Text war zu lang und das Bild nicht klar genug und spannend genug. Ja, da bin ich dann auch sehr schön abgelenkt. Aber ist es so, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht warum, aber hast du das Gefühl, dass wenn du Leuten Dinge empfiehlst, schau dir unbedingt den Film an, dass dann aus irgendeinem Grund die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie das tatsächlich anschauen, eher sinkt. Ich habe es bei mir. Also wenn nicht mir etwas empfohlen wird, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich es anschaue, geringer als vorher. Weil Leute, die mir Dinge empfehlen, sind oft in meiner gleichen Bubble. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich gucke ich das irgendwann auch, was er mir empfohlen hat. Wenn er mir das aber jetzt empfiehlt, weiß ich schon, es hat schon jemand gesehen aus meiner Bubble, irgendwie das Interesse lässt nach. Man will ja auch individuell sein. Wir sind ja auch eine Generation, die sehr auf Individualität setzt. Ich glaube, wir wollen auch gerne eine kontroverse Meinung haben oder einen kontroversen Geschmack haben. Und deswegen glaube ich, gucken wir dann eher was anderes, was noch niemand uns empfohlen hat, um dann diese ... Man will selber was finden. Es ist ja soziales Kapital, so eine Serie empfehlen zu können. Ja, Informationen, genau. Und ja, es ist irgendwie komisch, weil es ist auch komisch, wenn man damit schon reingeht in so eine Serie mit so einem Oh, die ist richtig gut. Habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass viele Leute da Hemmungen haben, eine Serie anzufangen, wenn sie das Gefühl haben, Oh, die wird richtig gut bewertet oder haben mir ganz viele Leute empfohlen, war man dann schon so eine Drucksituation, wohingegen man einfach mal so auf Netflix, also ich mag ja von Netflix die letzten drei Seiten, ich liebe die, so wirklich mal gib einen Suchbegriff ein und geh mal auf die letzten Seiten, was da für einen Schwachsinn ist, weil Netflix ist ja nicht irgendwie wie so ein Buch, das einen Anfang und ein Ende hat, sondern du hast ja immer diese vorgeschlagenen Sachen. Infinity Scroll, ja.
Das heißt, du kommst ja nie ans Ende so. Deswegen frage ich mich gerade, was du mit den
letzten drei Seiten meinst, weil
dann kommen ja am Anfang, dann kommt ja doch
wieder Adam Sandler am Ende. Ne, gib ein Wort ein.
Gib ein Wort ein, gib Bird ein.
Dann kommt Bird Box,
Birdie 2, Birdie 3,
Birdie 4. Air Force One?
Air Force One, ja, Birdman, Birds, Batman, Birdman, Birds, Hitchcock. Alle Filme von Aretha Bird. Richtig, ja. Birdie mit First Contact und so weiter. Es wird abstrakter auch relativ schnell. Es wird abstrakter. Und dann einfach mal drei Seiten weiter. Was dann kommt, unglaublich. Tolle Sachen, was man da findet. Wirklich ganz grauenvolle Dinge. Man hat ja das Gefühl, so Netflix steht für Qualität, da laufen nur fantastische Serien von fantastischen Autoren geschrieben. Aber da ist auch viel Bullshit, also viel grottenschlechter Bullshit, der irgendwo hinten versauert. Ja, ja, genau. Von dem man auch nichts mitbekommt. Das ist immer interessant. Ja, das finde ich spannend. Es gibt, ja, aber ich kenne das auch von mir, wenn mir was empfohlen wird, tendenziell. Aber ich weiß aber auch, dass wenn wir was empfehlen, häufig kommen Nachrichten. Also ich habe zum Beispiel von ein paar Wochen immer einen Song empfohlen. Ich habe noch nie so viel euphorisches Feedback bekommen, wie der sich mich angehört hat. Me and Julio down at the schoolyard von Paul Simon habe ich empfohlen. Die Leute waren glücklich danach. Also ich glaube, wenn wir was empfehlen, gucken sie es dann doch nochmal irgendwann. Da möchte ich was empfehlen. Ich möchte die Empfehlung aussprechen. Einfach mal, Fleabag. Es ist kein Geheimtipp mehr, vor allem nach den ganzen Emmys vorgestern Nacht, aber Holy Shit, das ist eine erschreckend gute Serie. Die ist so gut, dass ich traurig werde, wie schlecht ich bin als Autor. Ja, okay. Die ist so gut, dass ich wütend bin auf Phoebe Waller-Bridge. Aber dir ist schon klar, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt sinkt, dass ich es mir anschaue. Aber ich habe gehofft, dass meine Abmoderation der Empfehlung jetzt ein bisschen Wettmacht. Auch wenn ich einen lustigen Link kriege, ist oft, ich mache das Video auf, um zu gucken, wie lang es ist, warte dann die Zeit, ohne es anzuschauen, sobald die Zeit vorbei ist, ha ha ha. Ha ha ha? Drei H's? Ha ha ha. Ja. Ganz wichtig, drei H's. Ha ha ist eher sarkastisch. Aber das ist unterschiedlich. Wie viele Ha Ha's werten unterschiedliche Leute unterschiedlich sarkastisch. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Ha Ha oft schon sarkastisch ist. Was definitiv sarkastisch ist, ist Hi Hi. Hi Hi. Hi Hi ist definitiv sarkastisch, ironisch. Und es ist ausser im Flirty-Gespräch, ist hier immer so ein züchternes Lächeln. Ich habe neulich sehr viel Gegenwert bekommen für ein Nee mit einem N, mit einem E. Nee. Weil Nee ist so Näh. Es wurde gelesen als Näh. Dabei meinte ich Nee. Aber Nee ist, habe ich gesagt, das sind zwei Es. Ich habe zwei Es immer deutlich abwertender gelesen. Nee. Nee ein Nee. Nee. Und Nö, nee. Ja, genau. So, wohingegen Nee mit einem E dachte ich immer, wäre so ein Nee, so ein klassisches Nee. Und dann kommt noch was. Nee, ich gehe morgen dahin. So, aber verstanden wurde es als Nee. Nee. Und dann war die Person sauer auf mich, als ich aufgetaucht bin, weil sie dachte, ich habe so ne. Genau, es wurde mir nach, sollen wir dir was mitbestellen? Ich kam nach zu einer Veranstaltung, sollen wir dir auch, wir bestellen gerade Pizza, möchtest du auch was? Und ich habe geschrieben, ne, ich habe schon gegessen. Deswegen habe ich, ne, ich habe schon gegessen, aber mit einem E. Und es war, ne, ich habe schon. Ne, danke. Ne. Okay, Und ich stelle mir so gut vor, du kommst auf die Party und die Gesam alle starren dich wütend. Was für ein mieses Schwein. Ja, kommt hier an.
Nee, aber ne ist eher eh eigentlich. Eh, h hätte ich sogar gesagt.
Eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh.
Aber was ist mit N-E-H? Ich glaube, da müssen wirklich die Gesetzgebiete nochmal neu geschrieben werden. Die Knigge muss umgeschrieben werden. Jetzt in Zeiten der non-möbelbarer Kommunikation ist es schon ein Problem. Ich finde manchmal ist es auch, ich war lange skeptisch gegenüber Emojis, Und, mittlerweile denke ich mir, ja, hilft halt auch, um so einen Code mitzuschicken, wie man es zu lesen hat. Ja, ich bin nicht mehr so dogmatisch. Nee, gar nicht, aber es ist ja interessant, weil ich spiele jetzt gerade wieder World of Warcraft Classic, wo man ja auch viel schreibt, man kommuniziert mit seinen anderen Spielern und mit seiner Gilde und so immer in Schriftform. Und es ist ganz interessant, weil es gibt so eine Art, und ich weiß nicht, ob außerhalb Leute auch so schreiben, klar, es gibt diesen Gamerslanger, aber das meine ich gar nicht, und zwar gibt es Leute, die immer Worte mit so einer Art Dialekt schreiben. Also die statt Danke, Dange schreiben, D-A-N-G-E oder Bide, B-I-D-D-E, also wo man jetzt nicht sagen kann, ja genau, wo man jetzt gar nicht sagen kann,
es ist kürzer, also jeder kennt ja, dass man
Sachen abkürzt und THX statt Danke oder so
im Gännis-Lenken. Bei Böde ist mehr
Arbeit reingeflossen. Das Ü ist super weit weg.
Bei Umlauten, oh, da merkt man schon,
da muss Arbeit reinfließen in das Wort,
in die Wortkomposition. Und ich kann mir
beim besten Willen nicht erklären, warum Leute so
schreiben. Es ist ganz merkwürdig, weil es ist gerade
in WoW trifft mich das immer wieder,
weil das so eine Art von
Schrift ist, mit der ich sonst nichts zu tun habe, aber
Die Logik-Login aber am besten Willen nicht erklären, warum Leute so schreiben. Es ist ganz merkwürdig, weil es ist gerade in WoW trifft mich das immer wieder, weil das so eine Art von Schrift ist, mit der ich sonst nichts zu tun habe, aber die Leute kommunizieren immer so, so dange, bitte, fertig. Und ich denke so, es ist ja schon merkwürdig, dass man, also ist es deren Dialekt, den sie dann in Schriftform umwandeln, oder ist es die Art, wie sie mit ihren Freunden sprechen, ist es eine Art von, dass man Freundschaft nicht schreibt, weil du es bitte danke. Aber hast du das mal gefragt? Nee, habe ich nicht gefragt. Frag mal. Erst mal, ich habe direkt ein Bild von dieser Person im Kopf. Ja, genau. So ein 13-Jähriger. Weil ich, das kenne es doch von mir, weil ich habe das auch damals bei, als ich damals als Chatrooms und ICQ und so hochkam, da hat man ähnlich geschrieben. Das war so eine Chatform, da hat man wirklich komisch geschrieben. Ich habe da ehrlich gesagt eher alte Leute vor Augen, also eher so 45-Jährige, die da irgendwie das so lapidar, irgendwie keine Ahnung, weil es wirkt ja schon, Schriftform ist ja schon schwer, weil es oft sehr technisch wirkt, wenn du schreibst, bitte, danke, du hast ja oft keine Konnotation mit dabei, was freundschaftlich ist. Mittelding wäre, was machst du? Was machst du, genau. Ja, aber da hast du zumindest die Verkürzung drin. Bist du schon da? Und vor allem, also ich steche da wirklich stark raus, weil ich wirklich perfektestes Oxford-Deutsch schreibe. Also wirklich, möchtest du auch mitkommen in die Instanz? Fragezeichen, habe ich alles hoch, gross und klein geschrieben. Ja, gross und klein. Und man wirkt wie ein Arschloch. Jedes Komma sitzt bei mir auch. Ich war auch nervös, wenn ein Komma nicht sitzt. Ja, jedes sitzt. Und man wirkt einfach unsympathisch, weil alle so, dange, bitte, nee, kommst du, und du so. Du bist der Spießer, du bist einfach der, ja, du bist der geborene Spießer in der Internetwelt. Ich finde es nicht schlimm, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde es auch nicht so schlimm, aber ich finde es faszinierend. Also da gibt es bestimmt linguistische Auseinandersetzungen damit, warum Leute das machen. Da muss auch noch viel nachgeholt werden, genau, weil ich finde, es müssen auch Regeln her. Also was ist ein Ne mit einem E, was ist ein Ne mit zwei E? Ja, da ist es H-H-H-Hehe. Genau, wie lustig ist ein H-H-H-H. Manchmal baue ich sogar extra, wenn ich sagen will, wie lustig es ist, kein Scheiß, baue ich extra Fehler ein. Ich tausche ein A und ein H, damit du zwei A's. Ne, ne, ne, ne, das ist eine grössere Kette, das ist schon ein ha ha ha ha ha. Und da tausche ich manchmal das A und ein H, um halt diese Unregelmäßigkeit drin zu haben, von wegen schnell getippt.
Als würdest du so hart lachen, dass du deinen Körper nicht unter Kontrolle hast.
Das baue ich extra ein. Das ist dann so ein H, H, H, H, H, H, H, und dann in der Mitte, genau in der Mitte tauscht du A und H, und dann hast du zwei As und zwei Hs nebeneinander.
Das hat so ein Gefühl von, da ist so ein Rhythmus, da ist ein bisschen dynamischer, es wirkt nach einem grösseren Lachen automatisch.
Ja genau. Ja, genau. Also das ist ja, das mache ich dann auch schon bewusst teilweise, wirklich. Wahnsinn, nur damit Leute nicht denken, du würdest sie verarschen oder würdest sarkastisch meinen. Ja, ja. Und was man immer ja denkt, also ich sitze wahnsinnig lange an Nachrichten, Textnachrichten.
Ja.
Also weil Schrift ist eh meine Form, also ich kann besser schreiben als sprechen, viel besser. Und deswegen schreibe ich halt generell sehr gerne und versuche auch da immer neuen Layer reinzubringen, lustig zu sein und so. Bei mir fließt sehr viel Arbeit in Gespräche. Und manchmal lese ich die Nachricht, aber ich klicke nicht drauf, damit die zwei blauen Haken noch nicht kommen und denke einen Tag lang über diese Nachricht nach, die ich antworte. Das mache ich auch, ich überlege schon, also oft habe ich die Nachricht schon im Kopf, bevor ich anfange zu schreiben. Ich habe sogar Entwürfe, also mit meinen Notizen, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen unangenehm zuzugeben, aber wenn die Person mir wichtig ist, wenn es um einen Crush geht oder gut, okay, das ist noch gleich noch was, aber können wir mal in die Notizen reinschauen? Was da gerade so drin steht? Löschte nachher immer. Löschte immer! Ich komponiere eine Nachricht in der Notiz-App, weil ich Angst habe, die abzuschicken schon. Deswegen traue ich und damit auch nicht die besagte Person sieht, dass ich schreibe. Jaja. Das heißt, ich schreibe die Nachricht vor, aber verschiedene, auch mal, und wir kennen das ja, beim Brainstorming ist wichtig, gibt ja auch die neuner Regel, oder zehner Regel, jedenfalls, dass die neun von zehn Ideen scheiße sind. Deswegen ballere ich so die ersten Gedanken, die mir kommen, raus, weil ich will nicht die erste Idee haben, ich will nicht die erstbeste Nachricht zurückschreiben, sondern ich will ein cooleres Comeback haben. Aber was du jetzt auch vermeiden musst, ist, dass du unrealistisch kurz nur schreibst, dass da steht, Stefan schreibt, Stefan schreibt, und dann plötzlich kommt ein riesenlanger Text. Deswegen lasse ich sie drin, die Nachricht, so lange, wie ich brauchen würde, ich lese sie nochmal durch, wie sie brauchen würde zu schreiben, auf jeden Fall, das sind alles Gedanken, die ich mir mache. Aber wenn du den Text nur drin hast, Stefan schreibt, bumm, einfach zehn Zeilen, man denkt, what, da verrätst du dich ja, das mache ich nicht. Aber hat der andere auch die Punkte, wenn du weder schreibst noch löscht, einfach nur den Text drin stehen lassen? Nee, deswegen mache ich immer Leerzeichen löschen, Leerzeichen löschen, Leerzeichen löschen, Leerzeichen löschen. Weil dann ist auch egal.
Wenn dann Leerzeichen zu viel drin ist, ist ja egal, hinten raus.
Nee, da bin ich wirklich, da passe ich auf, weil da muss man wirklich gucken.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es immer die Frage, wie lange, wenn man, lass uns das mal ansprechen, wenn man mit einem Crush schreibt, wie lange lässt man sie warten, wie lange, wie lange, wie lange, weiß ich nicht, man will, sollte man sofort zurückschreiben, ist es nicht blöd, jemanden überhaupt warten zu lassen, ist es nicht so eine altmodische Kacke, aber man will auch nicht zu Nidi rüberkommen, dann ist man sauer, dass sie nicht zurückschreibt, denkt man aber, macht sie das jetzt, weil sie wirklich beschäftigt ist, weil sie mit nichts zurückschreiben will, weil sie mit meinem besten Freund schläft gerade, wahrscheinlich, genau, oder mit einem Familienteil schläft, oder einfach, weil sie wirklich beschäftigt ist, weil sie mit nichts zurückschreiben will. Weil sie mit meinem besten Freund schläft gerade? Ja, weil sie mit meinem besten Freund. Wahrscheinlich. Genau.
Oder mit einem Familienteil schläft.
Oder einfach, weil sie das genauso macht wie ich, was ja die naheliegendste
Lösung eigentlich wäre in den meisten Fällen.
Weil sie auch ein Mensch ist,
die auch nicht Bock hat,
sofort zu antworten. Ah, das ist so furchtbar.
Das ist schrecklich. Warum quälen wir uns alle?
Es ist einfach furchtbar, vor allem,
wenn man dann mit einer Person schreibt, die zum Beispiel auch in Social Media aktiv ist. Also ich will jetzt keinen Namen nennen, nennen wir sie mal Bema Bayer Bandboot. Ich habe an den gleichen Namen gedacht. Und dann schreibt man halt so persönlich ein bisschen hin und her und dann schreibt man und dann, hey, schreibt man und dann sieht man, ah, sie hat es gelesen. Bena hat es gelesen. Und. Bena und dann kommt nichts. Und dann kommt nichts. Und dann kommt ein Tweet aber. Und dann denkst du dir, du hast jetzt Zeit für einen Tweet, aber du hast keine Zeit, mir zurückzuschreiben. In Zeiten von Instagram-Stories noch schlimmer. Ja! Sie sieht deine Story, ich sehe ihr Face. Man muss auch sagen, Instagram hat's genailt, Instagram weiss genau, wen du gerade magst.
Die ersten drei unten, wenn du eine Story machst, die ersten drei Nasen, die du unten hast, sind die, die am wichtigsten sind. No questions. Instagram weiss es. Du meinst, die Story sieht ja als erstes angezeigt werden? Nee, die Leute, wenn deine Story geguckt wird, siehst du, von wem die unten geguckt wird. Ja. Und du, es sind immer die drei Nasen, die als Vorschaubild gelten, wo du auch draufklicken kannst, dann siehst du alle, die geguckt haben. Aber die drei Vorschaubilder schon unten, das sind immer die, die am wichtigsten sind. Und wenn da ihr Face bei ist, dann weißt du direkt, ah fuck, sie antwortet mir nicht mehr fucking Whatsapp. Ah, zum Glück mache ich keine Stories, das ist ja nochmal eine ganz neue Ebene. Wenn du Stories machst und man sich gegenseitig folgt, vor allem die heutige Jugend, Thais, wenn du zuhörst, gib uns mal ein Update, flirten in der Jugendkultur mit Stories und Tweets. Der beste Trick ist übrigens, geht in die Instagram-App, geht auf das Herz unten, wo ihr die Benachrichtigungen habt und dann swipet einmal nach rechts. Was dann kommt, ist die Stalking-Wunderwaffe. Du siehst nämlich von allen Leuten, was sie gerade geliked haben, wem sie gerade neu folgen. Das ist super spannend. Und dann siehst du nämlich zum Beispiel, ah, jetzt gefällt dir aber dieses Foto von diesem Surfer. Ja, Surfer. Werde ich auf deine Nachricht warte? Du hast dir gerade die Story von dem Surfer angeschaut.
Komisch, hm?
Und er muss einen Screenshot machen und einen schicken.
Und dann sagen, das echt, das machst du in der Zeit. Aber es stimmt schon mit den Stories, ne? Ach, das ist wirklich, du weißt gerade viel zu viel, das ist also, ich bin so froh, dass ich keine Stories mache. Ich wusste ganz genau, damals als es aufkam mit den Stories, wusste ich, wenn du da jetzt anfängst, dann steigerst du dich da so rein und dann irgendwie hast du Druck, jeden Tag was zu machen und dann fragst du, wie viel guckt es? Und ich dachte mir so, nee, da habe ich einfach keinen Bock drauf. Ich mache Podcasts, ich mache Moin Moin, ich haue mein Zeug raus, es passt schon, das kann ich einfach skippen. Weil das ist, glaube ich, das ist so kleinteilig und es nagt so an deinem Gehirn. Es nagt an deinem Gehirn. Und wollte ich das gar nicht das wäre sehr unangenehm zuzugeben aber ich glaube dass da werden sich viele auch drin welt selber drin wiederfinden heutzutage wenn du auf einem coolen event bist oder sowas was du wegen dir machst weil du da bock drauf hast es ist total blöd dass du die ganze zeit im kopf hast wie poste ich das jetzt vor allem wie poste das jetzt so dass es nicht unsympathisch wirkt, sondern dass es so nebenbei, mit einem Gag versehen am besten noch. Und du bist bei diesem Event oder bei dieser Abendveranstaltung tendenziell ja vielleicht aus guten Gründen, nicht weil du es für Instagram posten willst, sondern weil du sogar gerne bist, weil du was für dich tust. Aber wie poste ich es jetzt, damit es nicht so aussieht, als wäre ich nur für die Story da? Nur für die Story hier und nur deswegen da. Und trotzdem erwischt man sich immer dabei wie, ja, aber trotzdem will ich den Leuten jetzt sagen, was für ein tolles Leben ich habe und so. Weil du bist ja auch die ganze Zeit von tollem Leben umgeben. Und alle machen das ja. Und das ist ja so eine Normalität angenommen, dass du die ganze Zeit, du bist in so einem Wettbewerb, wo du dir sagen willst, was du für ein tolles Leben hast. Und das ist wirklich gefährlich. Ich glaube, da muss man sich davon lossagen.
Aber ich bin oft bei Events und denke mir, okay, wie poste ich es jetzt?
Nächste Woche ist Comedypreis wieder.
Du bist da, oder was? Ich bin da und ich werde natürlich wieder eine Story machen wollen, mein Über-Ich.
Oder mit Christian Tramitz hast du am Arm und dann ist da Jan Köppen dabei.
Christian Tramitz und Olivia Wyatt, nee, wer h wer hieß die, Gina, nee, Olivia Jones.
Was ist da mit? Die habe ich im Arm und du bist ein Tramilz. Das stimmt, das ist einfach der Royal Flush, das Comedypreis ist, da kann man nichts falsch machen. Ja, genau, und da werde ich dann auch versuchen, also man kennt sich ja auch, aber das ist doch Quatsch, da bin ich ja nicht wegen Instagram, weil es eine lustige Trash-Veranstaltung ist, auf die ich mich jedes Jahr erneut freue.
Ja, ich freue mich auf die letzten drei Jahre, wo ich nicht angetan wurde, aber na klar, ich meine, ich lege dann halt in der Badewanne und schaue dir dabei zu, wie du mit Oliver Jones ein bisschen rumshakerst.
Ihr habt da so eine tolle Chemie. Wir sind beide sehr gross. Ich freue mich schon wieder. Was hat sie hier dieses Jahr an? Welche Farbe trägt Oliver Jones dieses Jahr? Grün. Wahrscheinlich grün. Bulliparade, da habe ich jetzt ein YouTube-Video gefunden, so die gesamte Bulliparade als ein Video. Also 19 Stunden oder so. Alles, also alles ist auch nicht gut gealtert. Also ich mochte die Bulli-Parade sehr, aber interessant auch Bulli generell, Bulli-Sumor nicht gut gealtert. Überhaupt nicht. Also jetzt auch natürlich auch, weil ein paar Sachen einfach aus der Zeit gefallen sind. Da gibt es dann auch einfach Sketche mit dem Klischee-Asiaten, mit den zwei grossen Schneidezähnen und dem Hut und der gelben Hautfarbe. Und man denkt sich, hm. Also jetzt nicht, dass es unbedingt jetzt irgendwie deswegen schon automatisch nicht lustig ist, aber wenn das der gesamte Gag ist, also wenn dann nicht noch mal was draufkommt. Und das ist einfach der ganze Gag. Und dass er schwul ist, ist einfach der gesamte Gag. Das war es halt dann auch. Und das ist dann echt hart anzuschauen, weil ich habe das super in Erinnerung und dachte immer so, nee, wir hatten auch mal geile Comedy, wir hatten mal die Bulli-Parade, wir hatten Erker und Stefan, wir hatten TV Total, wir hatten richtig geilen Scheiss. Aber guckt man sich an und denkt sich, ja, vielleicht war ich einfach nur jung und fand alles lustig, was irgendwie tabuig ist. Ja, das war, glaube ich, der einzige Grund. Auch TV-Total rückblickend oder, ja.
Aber dann guckt man ins Publikum und die Leute lachen und dann denke ich mir sehr, ja gut, die sind auch nur 20 oder so, als die auch nicht. Das war auch so ein ganz seltsamer, ganz seltsamer Humor, der immer, ja, ganz merkwürdig. aber da ist ja immer ein gag dass jemand deutsch spricht drei Wörter, dass Thomas Gottschalk die Hand auf einen weiblichen Hollywood-Stars-Oberschenkel legt und so. Das waren ja immer die Gags. Also das waren ja wirklich, ich saß auch lachend, Tränen lachend vom Fernseher jedes Mal. Auch bei TV Total, auch damals bei Two and a Half Men oder Spongebob, aber man wächst halt auch raus. Das einzige, woran ich mich wirklich erinnern kann bei Wetten, das ist diese Schale-Gummibärchen. Wo ich mir immer dachte, wie geil ist das denn? Und die hat nie jemand gegessen. Und das, also ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, gibt's da, da wäre ein Zusammenschnitt mal geil, wie Hollywood-Promies aus Langeweile-Gummibärchen essen. Kennen die das? Ja. Ja. Also ich meine, da greift niemand rein, weil es auch so ein langer Arm ist. Du überlegst dir halt schon, okay, die Couch ist groß, der Tisch ist groß. Also man lässt die doch auch für die nächste Show drin. Haben die die nicht? Vor allem dann dachte ich mir so, ich meine, Thomas Gottschalk hat ja Werbung für Haribo gemacht, aber es ist ja trotzdem eine ZDF-Show. Die machen ja keine Werbung. Bei ZDF gab es ja auch immer richtig viel Gegenwind aufgrund von weirden Werbedeals. Auch diese Autos, die sie immer verlost haben. Das war auch mal nicht so ganz koscher. Bin ich mir nicht sicher. Aber gibt es Hollywood-Stars, die dann nach den Gummibären gefingert haben? Ich stelle mir so vor, wie wirklich George Clooney da sitzt und zweieinhalb Stunden kein einziges Wort versteht und sich nur denkt, ist mein Arm lang genug? Oder will ich jetzt richtig dumm aussehen, wenn ich zu den so mitten, während die anderen sprechen, wann ist der richtige Moment? Problem ist halt, dass du die ganze Zeit angesprochen werden könntest und hast irgendwann so ein Gummibärchen im Mund und dann muss man sagen, sind Gummibärchen noch nicht die besten Süßigkeiten für eine Talkshow. Und dann vor allem, wie viele nimmt man? Das ist ja auch mal so ein Ding. Besser als Chips, habe ich gerade noch überlegt.
Also besser Gummibärchen als so ein
Ja, das stimmt, aber...
Und dann die Kamera schwenkt so rüber und Gerard Butler
sitzt da mit einer Chipsfrischstüte in der Hand.
Das ist auch nicht geil.
Aber nimmt man, wenn du reingreifst,
nimmst du dann mehr als eins oder eins?
Ich nehme meistens aus Naivität ein, da kommt aber dann doch der Heisshunger und dann ärgert man sich, weil man ja schon mal, man hat ja schon mal die Hemmschwelle überquert, man war aber auch schon mal, also man hat die Mühe schon mal auf sich genommen, dann reift man nochmal rein und dann mehr. Man sollte direkt mehr nehmen. Immer mehr, immer mehr. Auch es gibt ja, also habe ich im Kino, sehe ich manchmal Leute, die Popcorn-Tüte haben und dann nehmen die einzelne Popcorn raus und essen die.
Einzeln, mit Zeigefinger, Daumen. mehr. Es gibt ja, also habe ich im Kino sehe ich manchmal Leute, die Popcorn-Tüte haben und dann nehmen die einzelne Popcorn raus
und essen die einzeln.
Mit Zeigefinger, Daumen.
Ja, das mache ich aber auch. Einzel?
Also das ist mir völlig unverständlich.
Popcorn fangen ab vier erst an,
überhaupt gut zu werden. Du musst den ganzen
Mund voll. Nee, aber dann hast du ja immer
diese Schaufel vom Mund.
Ja klar, Schaufeln. Schaufel vom Mund.
Das kannst du ja nicht ertragen.
Natürlich.
Da verliere ich auch immer Popcorns.
Aber einzeln und dann isst du, erst wenn du das erste gegessen hast, kommt es zweite.
Oder legst du die dann so zusammen rein und manch dann los.
Nee, schon einzeln.
Ich muss erst nachdenken, weil das ist ja schon Automatismus.
Ich bin aber auch kein Popcorn-Typ im Kino, ehrlich gesagt, immer eher ein Nacho-Typ. Und dann auch ein Nacho. Immer ein Nacho. Ja, was willst du denn machen? Schaufeln! Ich will möglichst wenig Schmutz an meinen Fingern haben und möglichst wenig von meiner Hand in meinem Mund. Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn du viele Popcorn nimmst und dann Ruhe und Mund, dann hast du ja immer die ganze Hand voller, ist kontaminiert mit Popcorn. Und dann machen wir uns das vor, der Snack ist nach fünf Minuten Film weg. Klar. So, dann hast du fünf Minuten Sitz dann da und dann hast du die offenen Hände so aufgeöffnet, weil du diese Snack-Hände hast, die Zuckerhände, da wird das viel unangenehm. Dann nur noch lieber, ich will möglichst wenig kontaminieren von meiner Hand und dann an der Hose. Ja,ose. Ich bin da echt schlimm, ich nehme auch Chipstüte, nimmst du wahrscheinlich auch einzelne Chips raus. Einzelne Chips raus. Ich nehme eine ganze Handvoll Chips, tu dann die Chips alle in meine linke Hand und nimm dann aus meiner linken Hand immer so zwei, drei gleichzeitig mit der rechten Hand in den Mund. Das macht gar keinen Sinn, da sind viel zu viele Iterationen. Sodass beide Hände maximal schmutzig werden
und möglichst mein gesamter Körper
einmal in diese Nahrungskette
mit involviert ist. Zu viele Iterationen.
Ich kenne aber
diesen Wunsch. Weißt du warum?
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich das Essen sehen will.
Ich will es sehen, bevor
ich es esse. Ich will genau sehen,
ah, da sind drei kleine ...
Ich glaube, es ist etwas Anales bei dir, ehrlich gesagt. Es fühlt sich so ... Doch, ich habe es nämlich im ganz Kleinen auch, und zwar damals als Doug Haffernan, gibt es eine Folge von King of Queens, wie er aufwacht und bedeckt ist mit Knochen von Chicken Wings. Er hat einen Eimer, seine Hand ist noch im Eimer und er wacht auf und er hat die und dann sagt Crabby er hat die und dann sagt Cary, ich habe tausend mal gesagt, dass du nicht auf deinem T-Shirt essen sollst, weil er isst die und legt die Knochen dann auf seinen Bauch, also auf seinen Shirt. Ja. Mega. Und ich fand das irgendwie nicht sexuell erregend, aber die Vorstellung, dass du dein Shirt dreckig als Kind, wenn du das siehst, dass du dein Shirt dreckig machen kannst, indem du diese fettigen Sachen auf deinem Shirt ablegst, fand ich irgendwie mega cool. Grossartig. Ja, und ich glaube, im Kleinen hast du das auch. Du hast es im Größeren, ich habe es im Kleinen, aber du hast es auch, dass du, ich weiß nicht, du willst es spüren, du willst es reingreifen, Mund schaufeln. Und vor allem, ja, ich mag es auch, Essen zu planen. Das ist für mich genauso wichtig wie das Essen zu essen, ist genauso, aha, welche Chipsgrössen haben wir denn überhaupt? Ah, es gibt die Krümel, es gibt die kleinen, die mittelgrossen und die ganz grossen und dann überlege ich mir, wie esse ich die zusammen. Jetzt nehme ich erst die kleinen und dann die grossen oder erst die grossen und dann die kleinen. Es kommt nur auf die Chipsart an. Wir reden jetzt von den Chips-Frisch-Fisch-Chips. Von normalen, ja, Funny-Chips.
Genau, die in verschiedenen Formen rauskommen, nicht die Stapelchips. Nein, nein, nein, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Stapelchips lecke ich erst ab, die gewösste Seite. Für mich eine der grössten Perversionen dieser Erde sind Stapelchips. Klar, Pringles hat wirklich ein paar gute Sorten, aber allein diese Konformität widert mich an. Ich mag, dass da Struktur drin ist. Ich mag, dass du erst die grossen und dann findest du unten im letzten Drittel nochmal einen grossen Chip und das ist der beste Chip, den du jemals hattest. Wenn du denkst, ah, die grossen sind alle schon weg und dann weiter, weiter, weiter klein und dann findest du noch einen grossen, geil. Ich esse wirklich seit mehreren Monaten keine Snacks mehr.
Und ich habe es nicht vermisst. Du kannst es so gut abtrainieren. Das ist wirklich so einfach. Irgendwann hast du dein Körper nicht mehr das Bedürfnis nach Zucker so sehr. Es hilft schon, glaube ich, ich hatte schon geholfen, dass ich Cola und generell, ich habe nur noch Wasser getrunken und alle kühlen Getränke, es ist nur noch Wasser eigentlich, das ist alles ersetzt, oder halt Tee oder sowas, wenn es mal heiß wird,
aber eigentlich gerne,
wenn das Getränke mal heiß werden soll,
aber sonst habe ich das wirklich versucht,
Kalorien abzulassen,
und dann hast du auch wirklich gar nicht mehr so viel Bedürfnis nach Zucker,
weil ich glaube, das befeuert dein Zuckerbedürfnis so sehr, diese ständige Cola oder Apfelschorle gesäuft,
auch Säfte, ich habe sehr viel Säfte gerungen,
alles nicht gut. Ja, bei mir ist es ein bisschen anders. Ich schaue mir das schon auch gerne rein. Ich schaue mir das gerne rein. Ich glaube, vielleicht war ich glücklicher zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ich weiß nicht, ich mag, ich mag, habe ich wirklich jetzt über mich selber gelernt, ich liebe Rituale. Ich mag es, Dinge immer gleich zu machen und bestenfalls jeden Tag.
Immer so, ich mache auch wirklich fast alle Dinge gleich.
Zum Beispiel, wenn mein Essen fertig ist, dann nehme ich mein Essen mit und dann lege ich die Mate ins Gefrierfach.
Und dann esse ich das Essen und dann ist die Mate genau richtig, dass ich sie trinke. Und manchmal habe ich so dieses Gefühl, ich will gerade überhaupt keine Mate trinken, aber sie muss getrunken werden, weil sie ist im Gefrierfach und das Ritual gibt es vor. Ich muss das jetzt machen. Und dann muss er auch die Bibel zitieren. Und dann, ja, es ist wirklich so, es hat so seinen Ablauf. Ja, kein Fan von Ritualen. Doch, ich liebe Rituale. Ich bin jetzt mittlerweile ein Fan von sich treiben lassen. Gucken, was der Tag bringt. Carpe diem einfach, einfach gucken, was passiert. Gar nicht carpe diem, also da hintersteckt kein Zwang, jetzt den Tag sonderlich gut ausnutzen zu müssen und keine Stunde verstreiten zu lassen. Nein, einfach sich treiben zu lassen, mal gucken, wenn jetzt ein Kollege fragt, hast du nach der Arbeit Lust, weiß nicht, nochmal in die Stadt? Ich sag, wirklich? Einfach mal Ja's, mehr Ja's geben. Du treibst an Orte, dann lernst du auch viel über dich selbst. Du treibst an Orte, wo du merkst, da wollte ich nie hin. Und ich will nicht mit Kollegen da arbeiten in die Stadt. Aber auch, das ist eine gute Erkenntnis über dich. Aber ich lasse mich da ein paar Tagen treiben. Also wenn mir jetzt Fremde die richtigen Fragen stellen würden, kann es sein, dass ich nächste Woche nicht mehr hier bin oder plötzlich eine Tattoo hast, eine Tattoo habe, ja, es kann, es ist gerade in so einer wilden Phase, wo ich einfach mal kurz, ich lasse mich gerne, bin gerne unterwegs. Ist das der neue Stefan, ist das die neue Phase des Stefan, das ist der Jahr Stefan. Ja, Stefan ist vielleicht eine Phase, ja, aber ich mag die Phase gerade ganz gern, man, ich weiß nicht. Du packst das Leben bei den Hörnern, habe ich das Gefühl. Ist vielleicht auch bei den Hörnerer Hinterbeinen, ich weiß noch nicht genau, wo ich da hingreife.
Was mir aber auffällt, ist, dass es vielleicht zu Ende Ich weiß nicht. Du packst das Leben bei den Hörnern, habe ich das Gefühl. Ist vielleicht auch bei den Hörnern oder Hinterbeinen.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau, wo ich da hingreife.
Was mir aber auffällt, ist, dass es vielleicht am zu Ende gehenden Sommer liegt,
wo ich wieder das Gefühl habe, den nicht optimal genutzt zu haben.
Karpe Sommerum, weil der jetzt vorbei ist und man weiß nicht,
jetzt wird es halt kühl und es ist wieder diese Scheiss-Kack-Jahreszeit,
wo man nicht rausgehen will und so. Das ist auch befreiend auf eine Art, weil man nicht mehr so viel, wenn man drinbleiben im Sommer vorbei ist. Ja, nee, ich habe Angst, dass er jetzt vorbei ist und ich den ja nicht genutzt habe, weil wegen Arbeit und dann ist man, dann setzt so eine ja komm, jetzt lasse ich mich nochmal treiben, Mentalität ein, bin mir nicht sicher. Ich kenne auch, es befreit auch, der Winter befreit total, das kenne ich.
Ja, ich kenne dein Gesicht.
Nein, nein, mir ist gerade was eingefallen,
wo ich mich, glaube ich, bei wahrscheinlich dir und auch bei allen Hörern extrem unbeliebt mache.
Und zwar, ähm.
Wie formulierst du es jetzt am besten?
Es ist jetzt September, ne?
Ich habe letzten Monat mir schon Lebkuchen geholt. Oh, du bist das Problem. Ich bin das Problem. Du bist es. Ich oute mich, ich bin derjenige. Du bist der eine, wo sie sagen, und wenn es einer kauft. Richtig. Und wenn es einer kauft, ich glaube nicht, dass Rewe-Mitarbeiter so denken, wenn es einer kauft, ist ja gut. Sagen, einer glücklich wird. Und ich glaube, nichts hassen Menschen so gemeinsam so sehr wie, oh, ihr kommt jedes Jahr früher Weihnachtsgebäck und so. Und ich, ich hole mir mein Magenbrot. Ich hole es mir. Lebkuchen. Ich hole es mir, ich hole es mir einfach. Oh, diesen Hass, ich spüre den Hass aller Hörer, ich spüre ihn. Ich frage mich, bei mir ist es eine Mischung, offen gesagt, ist es bei mir eine Mischung aus Hass und Bock auf Lebkuchen.
Ja, weil ich meine, Lebkuchen, ich kann es ja verstehen zu sagen, es ist geiler, wenn es nicht immer gibt und so, aber jetzt, ihr würdet ja auch nicht sagen, wenn Kinderbueh nur einfach sechs Monate im Jahr nicht verfügbar wären, würde ich sagen, oh geil. Ah, ich habe noch nicht Werbung gesehen, weil ich mal wieder Fernsehen geschaut habe,
wiederweise kam Werbung für Ferrero Rocher.
Und zwar, ah, Ferrero Rocher ist jetzt aus der Sommerpause zurück. Ah, echt? Und ich dachte, what? Erstmal traurig, Sommer vorbei. Zweitens, Ferrero Rocher hat eine Sommerpause? Why? Und dann ist es immer noch ein bisschen wie Lebkuchen. Ferrero Rocher hat eine Sommerpause, das gibt es nur in der kühlen Jahreszeit. Was jetzt auch zurückgekommen ist, ist das Frufo. Das Podcast-Frufo? Wo wir natürlich die grosse Werbe mit Gelegenheit aller Zeiten verpasst haben, das Podcast-Frufo. Frufo ist zurück, vielleicht erinnerst du dich, ne, dieser flache Becher, wo richtig, was geil war, weil du
hast richtig viel Joghurt gesehen.
Der war sehr flach, aber sehr breit einfach, sehr grosse Fläche dieser Becher, wie ein
Ufo halt so.
Und du hast erst mal gesehen, das ist ein Meer an Fruchtjoghurt und ich kann da reinlöffeln,
weil das ist ja das grosse Problem, wir müssen nämlich über Fruchtzwerge reden, wurde irgendwie
zwei Löffel und dann ist es leer und du denkst dir, fuck you und du bist wütender, als
du davor warst.
Und du bist am nächsten direkt.
Vielen Dank. weil das ist ja das grosse problem müssen wir über fruchtzwerge reden wurde irgendwie zwei löffel und es leer und du denkst ja fuck you und du bist wütender als du davor warst und du bist am nächsten direkt und froffo war einfach riesengroß und jetzt kommt froffo zurück und denkst dir geil und was ist es normaler becher kein spielzeug nein normal froffo du hattest den großen breiten becher schön flach du hattest es mehr du denkst dir das hört nie auf und dann ist noch ein Spielzeug drin und jetzt ganz normaler Becher. Was ist denn dann noch vom Frufo übrig geblieben überhaupt? Das ist nicht das Frufo, was ich lieben gelernt habe. Zum Glück kann ich das hier so sagen, weil wir uns nicht haben einfangen lassen vom Frufo-Traktorstrahl. Stell dir vor, wir können jetzt nicht ernsthaft über Frufos reden. Naja, wir können auch über Technikerkranktenkasse reden, die super sind. Die sind mega, muss man schon auch sagen. Und also das hat mich schockiert. Ja, das hat mich schockiert. Ich muss, es geht eine Storyline weiter, die wir geliebt haben und die ich zu hassen gelernt habe. Ein neues Haustier? Mittlerweile habe ich mich aber auch wieder distanziert. Nein, ein neues Portemonnaie! der herr ich bin weg vom klassischen portmonee hin zur geldklammer es ist eine magnetische leder geldklammer so wieder viel zu teuer machen wir uns nicht vor zwei 10er blitzen raus es blithner raus, ja. Und du hast einen Schlagmagneten. Und du hast vorne Karten drin. Ich habe mir die Frage zwischendurch durchaus mal gestellt, liebe Hörer, ob dieser Magnet meine Karten beschädigt. Binst du der Entscheidung gekommen, naja, die würden das ja nicht verkaufen und es würde ja keine magnetischen Geldklammern geben, wenn es ein Problem wäre. Erster Tag, Nacherhalt des Portemonnaies. Erstmal passen nicht so viele Karten rein, wie ich dachte, sondern ich muss auf wichtige Karten verzichten. Personalausweis dachte ich mir, wofür brauche ich den jeden Tag? Also ich habe mich gegen ein paar Karten entscheiden müssen, die wenig wichtig sind, weil es passen nur circa sechs Karten rein. Und da habe ich mich jetzt wirklich gegen Karten entschieden wo ich dachte oh mein gott da sollte man schon also so ich muss jetzt aktiv an meine krankenkassenkarte denken wenn ich zum arzt gehe weil die nicht mehr hier rein passt das ist der grad an wichtigkeit den die karten drin haben die jetzt drin sind erster tag nach erhalt ist ich wollte meinen kaffee kaufen für zwei euroaffee. Wollte ich mir kaufen, hatte kein Bargeld, weil ich war noch nicht dabei, war zugekommen, habe mir eine Karte zahlen wollen, Karte ging nicht. Und es war eine Summe, wo man sagt, ja, wahrscheinlich habe ich noch 2,80 Euro auf dem Konto. Und nee, ging einfach nicht, Karte ging nicht. Und ich dachte mir, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein. Am selben Tag habe ich geparkt, habe ein Parkticket gezogen, Parkticket auch reingeklemmt, bin zurückgekommen, Parkticket reingesteckt, Parkticket nicht lesbar, destroyed einfach. Und dann habe ich, dann muss ich auf diesen großen Knopf drücken vom Parkticketautomaten. Diesen Ich-bin-ein-voll-Idiot-Knopf. Dieser, ja, der Ich-bin-, what the fuck, der Parkticket verloren Knopf eigentlich. Wo dann, man muss sagen, also man kennt diese Automaten ja, und ich habe schon darauf eingestellt, dass ich die Stimme nicht verstehen werde. Das sind diese alten, zugeschmutzten, man fragt, was ist das für ein Dreck da drin, ist immer braun, beschmutzt, man weiß nicht, was das für ein Dreck drin ist. Man lehnt sich schon so ran, weil man kennt das, man hört diese Stimmen nicht. Erst geht ein Warnton los, ein Wählton, der aber nicht so ein Dö, Dö ist, sondern so ein Nö, Nö, Nö, wirklich laut. Alle gucken, das ganze Parkhaus ist verwirrt. Dann geht eben eine Stimme an und die war unglaublich laut, glasklar, als würde sie neben mir stehen und unglaublich laut. Ich war, ich habe mich sehr erschrocken, weil ich sehr nah davor gesessen habe und dann, ja, habe ich gesagt, ja, wahrscheinlich habe ich die Karte mit Magneten zerstört. Mit meiner Magnetklemme zerstört. Ich bräuchte eine neue. Ja, wie wollen Sie denn bezahlen? Haben Sie Bargeld? Nein, ich habe kein Bargeld. Er versucht es mal mit Ihrer Karte. Ich habe mich die Karte reingesteckt, ging wieder nicht, weil der Magnet hat alles kaputt gemacht. Die hat auch meine Magnetklemme. Ja, ich hätte nicht... Ja, so, dann.
Es geht weiter.
Und dann muss ich mir wirklich von einem Fremden zwei Euro geben lassen.
Unsere Theorie ist bestätigt.
Man gibt eher mir zwei Euro als einem Obdachlosen. Irgendwie, random, alterer Mann hat mir zwei Euro gegeben, weil er auch sehr genervt war von der lauten Stimme, die auf einen brüllt. Eingesteckt kam dann ein neues Ticket raus und dann konnte ich das neue Ticket benutzen und dann war ich erst mal sehr sauer auf dieses Portemonnaie und wählte mich dann ein in mein Online-Banking-Account, um eine nicht dazuzugehörende andere Überweisung zu tätigen. Kommt raus, ja, ich bin massiv im Minus. Ich bin unglaublich viel Geld im Minus, weil ich eine Steuervoraussahlung übersehen habe. Plottwist, die Karte wurde nicht zerstört,
sie geht,
Parkticket wurde zerstört,
durchaus. Und es wäre gut, wenn ihr ein paar
T-Shirts kauft, weil Stefan
ist ein bisschen der Kreide.
Karten für unsere Tour kaufen.
Stuttgart ist schon ausverkauft, Köln ist schon
ausverkauft, aber ihr müsst,
komm, Mainzer, Leute, mit Zähnabfall,
schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell. Stefan braucht seinen Kaffee. Nicht Nachname, einfach direkt bezahlen. Genau, jetzt ist es so, dass die Parktickets offensichtlich zerstört werden von diesem starken Magneten, aber die anderen Tickets, also meine Karten gehen alle noch, das ist die lütliche Nachricht. Ich war kurz sehr sauer, mittlerweile habe ich mich daran gewöhnt, das ist eigentlich ein ganz cooles Portemonnaie.
Aber wofür ist der Magnet, damit die Klemme Geld hält? Ach so, aber du kannst nicht einfach eine normale Federklemme. Hält er mal auch, ich wollte gerne Magnet, bin großer Magnet-Fan. Krass, ich hätte nur gedacht, dass du irgendwie kannst dich zahlen und dann ja gut, dann fahre ich halt wieder und versuchst, deinen Autoschlüssel zu benutzen, der geht auch nicht mehr. Einfach alles ist durch und die Brille beschlägt und du bist einfach komplett ausgenockt. Und so ein anderes Auto gibt so Gas, weil es rangesogen wird von meinen Magneten. Ja, aber es ist verrückt. Diese Woche habe ich erst ein Stand-Up-Special von Brian Regan gehört. Ist ein ganz klassischer... Reagan. Brian Reagan? Nee, keine Ahnung. Ronald Reagan.
Ist ein ganz sehr sauberer und sehr klassischer Stand-up-Comedian, auch aus den 90ern oder so, aber super lustig, kann man sich super gut angucken. Und irgendwie gar nicht so wie heute, edgy Comedians, oh Leute, ich hab hier Stress auf Twitter, sondern einfach sehr familienfreundlich. Und der hat erzählt, wie auch immer, also mit Hotels, dass die Magnetkarten oft nichtieren. Und er dann zur Tür geht und wieder zurück geht zur Rezeption und die dann fragen, ja, kann es sein, dass sie Magneten dabei haben? Und er sagt dann so, ach ja stimmt, ich bin Magnetverkäufer von Beruf und habe meine ganzen Kostproben im Sack und da habe ich meine Karte reingeworfen. So im Sinne von, kein Mensch hat Magneten dabei, warum ist das die erste Frage, die sie stellen? Und jetzt kommst du und erzählst, wie deine Karten von Magneten zerstört werden. Das heißt, du hättest in dem Special gesessen und gesagt, warum lachen jetzt alle? Ich habe auch gerade gedacht, war das gerade die Punchline? Hier Magneten, Natasche. Aber sehr, sehr lustig, schaut euch das auf jeden Fall an. Meine Hand ist eingeschlafen. Was ist mit einer Hand passiert? Meine Hand ist eingeschlafen, ein Daumen ist eingeschlafen, von allen Sachen ist nur mein Daumen. Ja, deine linke Hand sollte nicht einschlafen. Nee, linker Daumen. Linke Arm. Linker Daumen. Linker Daumen ist gleich positiv, ist Thumbs Up. Ja, nee, bei linker Armen werde ich mal vorsichtig. Ja, manchmal muss sein Kreislauf auch Feedback geben und sagt dann so, der rechte Daumen, Thumbs Up. Einfach so, passt schon. Ich habe auch seit Tagen so ein weirdes Gebrechen wieder, ich habe einen ganz seltsamen Geschmack im Mund. Ja, Metall? Das ist Radioaktivität. Wenn du Metall schmeckst, ist es Radioaktivität. Ich weiß, ich habe es gegoogelt, Geschmack im Mund, und dann war das erste, was bekam Metall. Ich habe so einen Chlor-artigen Geschmack im Mund. Hast du Zahneinlagen oder sowas? Gar nicht, war erst beim Zahnarzt. Alles gut, perfekte Zähne. Das ist der einzige Körper, da ich keine Probleme habe. Die sind nicht zu groß, die sind nicht zu klein. Alles cool. Zähne ist tiptop. Aber ich habe so einen weirden Geschmack im Mund. Den habe ich manchmal. Ich rieche auch nach Chlorgeruch. Es ist Epilepsie. Also bleibt gespannt, wohin sich das entwickelt. Ich habe überlegt, mal zum HNO zu gehen. Ich habe immer so einen Druck auf meinen Ohren, das ist auch weird.
Auch komisch, ne? Sollte man nicht haben.
Ich glaube, du gehst vor allem erst zum HNO,
bis du einen Hals, einen Nasen und einen Ohrenleiden hast,
damit es sich lohnt. Einfach full house.
Hals und Nase habe ich ja jetzt,
durch diesen Witten-Claw-Geruch und Geschmack.
Und jetzt habe ich auch noch Druck auf den Ohren.
Der HNO hat bewegen, der kann drei Kreuze machen.
Der will nicht, der hüpft in die Luft vor Freude, Luft vor Freude, er sagt, jajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajajaj Schmecken und riechen. Man hat doch einen Favoriten, oder? Ja. Also es kann doch nicht sein, dass er so, Herr Patient, was fehlt Ihnen? Ja, ich habe Schmerzen, ja, ja, ja, in meinem Ohr. Oh, fucking Ohr! Hol den Rüssel! Immer diese Muscheldinger, alle immer mit ihren Ohrenkack. Wie ein Ruschelröhrchen hier. Nase, oder? Komm mal rein. Du willst ja die fremden Leute Nasen eher rum...
Naja, gute Frage. Was findest du ekliger? Die man mit dem Finger in den Mund, Nase oder Ohr zu stecken? Von am wenigsten eklig bis zum ekligsten... Also drei, deine drei kommen jetzt und meine drei, am wenigsten eklig, der drei Dinge.
Was würdest du am ehesten bei einem Obdachlosen eine Finger annehmen?
Okay, jetzt, warum reden wir seit Wochen über Obdachlose?
Nee, ich meine nur.
Es kommt natürlich klar auf den Hygiengrad an, aber ich würde schon sagen.
Drei ist bei mir definitiv Mund.
Am wenigsten eklig? Ich würde auch sagen, Mund am wenigsten eklig. So, dann. Nee, Mund ist zwei. Mund ist zwei. Ohr ist am wenigsten. Nee, Ohr ist am ekligsten. Ohr ist eins, Nase zwei. Ja, aber die Frage ist halt, wie tief so, wenn du jetzt... Nee, schon mal einmal rein. Ja, wie einmal rein? Einmal rein. Bis zum Anschlag. Einmal bis zum Anschlag rein. Mit dem Zeigefinger. Mit dem kleinen Finger. Ja, du kannst nicht die Regeln ändern jetzt die ganze Zeit. Das ist die sehr spezifische Liste gerade. Was ist am ekligsten, also wir machen das für jeden Finger, wir machen jetzt für jeden Finger und jeden Zeh, machen wir jetzt, welche Körperzeit am ekligsten sind. Und welche Tiefe. Nee, ich würde sagen, Zeigefinger bis zum Anschlag rein. Nee, dann finde ich die Ohr okay. Ohr am wenigsten, dann Mund und Nase ist am schlimmsten. Nase am schlimmsten. Aber auch weil Nase, da habe ich Angst, dass was bricht und das hat auch was mit Atmung zu tun. Und da hätte ich irgendwie, also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. So auch wenn du sagst einen zehn Zentimeter langen Stab, in welches Körperöffnung steckt man den rein und was ist am Ekelhaften. Oh, da bin ich auch. Und da definitiv Nase... Stab, aber was für ein Stab, Glas? Ich habe jetzt an Edelstahl gedacht. Ah, okay. Weil die Nase geht auch so direkt... Spitz zulaufen? Nein, stumpf. Stumpf? Stumpf, abgerundet. Mit so einem Gummi-Box? Abgerundet, nein, nein, nein, abgerundet. Aber Nase finde ich am schlimmsten und, ach, Ohren ist bei mir eh so ein Thema. Aber ich meine, Hals, Nasen müssen Favoriten haben. Die müssen einen Favoriten haben. Wo man sagt so, Hals, Nasen, Ohren und dann ist so auf dem Praxis Ohr durchgestrichen, so, Ohren mache ich nie mehr. Diese Bitte-keine-Werbung-Schilder, die man erkennt von Briefkästen, bitte keine Ohren, bitte keine Ohrpatienten mehr. Dann sagen die dann auch ihre Sekretärin dann immer, ihre Vorzimmerangestellten, muss ja nicht natürlich Pause sein. Bitte keine Ohren, bitte Ohren. Nehmen wir heute keine, ne bitte Peter, nehmen wir kurz keine Ohrenpatienten mehr an. Dankeschön. Rufen wir Leute an. Ja, um viert ist der Termin. Was? Meine Ohren sind geschwollen. Ich habe auch meine Ohren geschwollen. Das ist dann super scheiße. Sch Schwollen? Ja, halt Gehörgangsentzündung.
Und dann ist sie zugeschwollen und dann, das ist das Dumme, weil du denkst dir, das erste Ohr schwillt
zu und denkst dir, ich höre nichts auf dem rechten Ohr.
Aber zwei Ohren, kein Problem!
Ja, aber geht auch sofort
aufs andere Ohr über, weil irgendwie die Bakterien
fahren einmal um die Ecke.
Um beides. Oder halt so
Kopfkissen, erst rechtes Ohr, dann linkes Ohr
und dann so. Schläfst du lieber auf der linken oder auf der rechten Seite? Boah, halt die Fragen, Alter, ey. Ich glaube, eher linkes Ohr. Das sind schwierige Fragen. Weil ich habe lieber den rechten Arm oben, weil da fühle ich mich besser beschützt. Ja? Ja, es ist für mich so ein... Hand am Schwert. Ja, aber so einzwängiger, irgendwie so. Aber es ist ja... Ich fühle mich in beide Richtungen massiv unsicher, deswegen ist mir das egal. Das ist die ganze Nachtangst. Ich habe eine Bettseite, die das an der Wand liegt. Und da habe ich halt eher im Rücken. Aber lieber Gesicht zur Wand als Gesicht zum Baum. Nee, Gesicht zur Wand, nee, dann sehe ich den Feind nicht kommen.
Komplett konträr eigentlich wir beide?
Kann sein. Du magst Sommer, ich mag Winter.
Du magst
Gesicht zum Zimmer, ich mag
Gesicht zur Wand. Nee, wir sind so
Sinus, Cosinus.
Manche Bereiche sind wir sehr unterschiedlich,
aber wir sind bei genauso vielen
Sachen auch sehr, sehr gleich.
Wir sind einfach verschoben, so ein bisschen.
Auch liegt ein bisschen am Alltag, glaube ich, so wellenförmig. Man entwickelt sich ja, wir sind vier Jahre auseinander, drei Jahre auseinander.
Ja. Ich glaube, da entwickelt man in diesen, man entwickelt sich auch so wellenförmig.
Du, Leben ist ja so ein Pendel, so mal bist du der Meinung, man muss eine ganz krasse Meinung haben, dann brauchst du so drei Jahre und dann bist du da bei der Meinung, das Pendel schwingt rüber, man braucht keine krasse Meinung, gemässigte Meinung reicht vollkommen aus und so, wer bin ich, eine krasse Meinung zu haben?
Und so pendelt man hin und her, auch politisch, zwischen links und rechts, zwischen Antisemit und superliberal. Von daher ist es doch völlig okay, dass jeder ... Ich glaube, wir sind ein paar Jahre auseinander einfach, genau in diesem Pendel. Kann das sein? Kann schon sein. Bei vielen Sachen sind wir auch sehr ähnlich. Ja. Sagen wir mal HNO. Was würdest du am ehesten behandeln, Hals, Nase oder Ohren? Am ehesten behandeln würde ich gerne. Ich habe mein Ergebnis. Nase. Ohr. Auch kontraktisch. Auch alles anders. Würdest du im Casino eher auf Rot oder auf Schwarz setzen? Eher auf Schwarz. Ja, eher auf Rot. Wirklich? Ja, lass es hier einfach mal lassen. Wir sind komplett durch, es ist schwierig, vor allem, es gibt es ja auch bei so Hochzeitsspielen, wie gut gut kennt sich das Brautpaar. Ich habe mal bei einem interessanten Projekt mitgemacht, und zwar einem improvisierten Film. War ein Film, der war komplett improvisiert. Jeder hat eine Rolle bekommen. Hätte ich mir fast gedacht an dem Namen. Ja, eine Rolle, das ist ein Science-Fiction-Thriller. Jeder hat eine Rolle bekommen und dann, das war der Abend vor der Hochzeit. So, nochmal alle kommen zusammen, Braut und bräutigam und die besten freunde und eltern und so und dann hat die regisseurin halt so viele konflikte angelegt halt so die die eine steht noch auf den und die eltern wissen nix dass die mal abgetrieben hat bla bla bla so ganz viele dinge die potenziell rauskommen können ich würde mal so ein cloedo film machen ja wo du sagst dem einen der ist der Mörder, Reverend Grün ist der Mörder, dem sagst du das, und dann einfach legst du so Konflikte an, dem sagst du, du hast die umgebracht und so, und dann sagst du, gibst du manchen, den ich hinweist, der weist jedenfalls, der hat die Mordwaffe gesehen, um diese Uhrzeit und so, muss er vorher halt genauso überlegen, dass es lösbar ist, aber dann lässt du dir einfach, dann mietest du dir für einen Abend lang so eine Villa, so eine krasse, coole Villa und dann drehst du da alles mit. Ja, das ist spannend, als Pen and Paper. Können wir auch als Pen and Paper machen. Und da gab es dann eben auch so den Punkt, wo die dann so Spiele gespielt haben und dann eben auch dieses, kennt man ja so bei zwei besten Freunden, wer von euch kann besser singen und dann müssen beide so Zettel hochhalten der eine oder andere und das war deswegen sehr lustig weil wir alle in den Rollen waren und die auch wir aber natürlich nur begrenztes Wissen zu den Charakteren hatten das heißt teilweise haben Braut und Bräutigam saßen dann so Rücken an Rücken und dann war so die Frage, wo hattet ihr euren ersten Kuss oder wer hat wen geküsst beim ersten Kuss? Was man wissen soll, was beide wissen sollen. Was man ja eigentlich wissen kann, aber die halt nicht wussten, aber nicht weil sie jetzt irgendwie ihr Partner nicht wert ist, sondern weil die Schauspieler schlicht nicht wussten diesen Fakt. Und dann mussten die irgendwas sagen und dann hatten sie unterschiedliche Ergebnisse und dann beide so, wie? Und dann musste man irgendwie die Reaktion darauf spielen, obwohl beide ja wussten, dass es sozusagen eine Outgame-Situation war, die jetzt hier gerade geklärt wurde und alle so, wie du weisst nicht, wo ihr euch das erste Mal geküsst seid. Und Das war so merkwürdig, weil man musste ja in der Rolle,
man musste das ja bis zum Ende spielen.
Und daraus ist ein richtiger Streit entstanden,
einfach nur, weil es gar nicht lösbar war, dieses Rätsel.
Es war sehr interessant.
Aber hat sie das gewollt, oder hat sie den beiden durchaus gesagt,
wo sie sich geküsst haben zuerst mal?
Nee, sie wussten es einfach nicht.
Da waren Fragen drin, ich weiss noch nicht,
ob die Fragen alle geplant waren oder ob die andere Schauspielerin die improvisiert hat.
Ja, genau.
Weil dann fährt man sich in so eine Sackgasse und dann so, keine Ahnung, wer hat für ihren ersten Urlaub gezahlt? Wie, das weißt du nicht, was du mir sonst bedeuten? Kann auch angelegt gewesen sein, das weiss man nicht. Ganz interessant und spannend. Und dann, wie geht der Film aus? Ich möchte nicht sagen, möchte nicht verraten. Kann man den gucken irgendwo? Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht. Das war so ein Filmschulen-Abschlussfilm-Ding. Und vor allem, ich hatte richtig, fand ich, richtig schöne Szenen, ohne dass die Kamera im Raum war. Das war natürlich auch so. Vor allem der Bräutigam hat dann nochmal gezweifelt und hat sich im Klo eingesperrt und ich war der beste Freund vom Bräutigam und bin dann so nochmal zu ihm ins Klo und habe nochmal auf ihn eingeredet.
Aber warum gehst du ins Klo, wenn die Kamera nicht dabei ist? Weil wir die Rolle, weil wir nicht fünf Filmen spielen so, weil als bester Freund ist das deine Aufgabe, du musst dann da unterstützen. Ja, aber du bist ja auch gerade Schauspieler, du machst ja gerade einen Film. Ja, aber du kannst ja nicht sagen, willst du nicht doch mal rauskommen und dich in der Banane für ein wenig Aufstellung anstellen. Nee, ich würde nicht spielen, bis die Kamera nicht endlich auf mir ist. Aber es ist eine ganz merkwürdige Situation, weil dann gibt es irgendwie so einen Gefühlsausbruch und alle stehen nur so rum und denken, komm jetzt nicht, komm, ganz merkwürdig. Man ist immer so halb in der Rolle und halb draußen. Ja, ja. Aber es hat schon Spaß gemacht. Spannend, spannend. Ganz spannend auf jeden Fall. Sehr wenig relatable, aber sehr schön. Überhaupt nicht relatable, vor allem wir waren dann auch unterwegs und waren dann auch in der Bar und da so der Barkeeper und so, wir waren halt nicht eingeweiht. Das war halt teilweise so abstrus, weil teilweise auch solche Dramamomente kamen. Und der Barkeeper so, wie jetzt erfährt die Mutter, dass ihre Tochter abgetrieben hat? Und alle so, was, das darf nicht sein! Und der Barkeeper so, was ist hier los? Ich war in einer ich war in ganz seltsamer Situation.
Ich war in Düsseldorf und dann plötzlich kam ein Paar vorbei, nee, das war eine Familie, mit einem Kinderwagen und halt ein Paar. Und plötzlich hat der Mann, genau in dem man an mir vorbei war, so direkt als er die größtmögliche Nähe hatte zu mir, sagte er, Ja, ich bin dafür, dass wir gleich mal Cappuccino trinken gehen, darauf hätte ich jetzt richtig Lust. Und die Mutter sagte, ja, genau, lass uns das jetzt tun. Und dann gehen sie weiter und ich habe gehört, dass sie nicht mehr weitersprechen. Und das war der merkwürdigste Moment der letzten zehn Jahre, ich schwöre es dir. Ich weiss nicht genau, was da passiert ist, aber es wirkte wie ... Die Matrix war nicht breit, dass ich plötzlich in Düsseldorf bin, hat mich da nicht erwartet und brauchte jetzt irgendwo schnell noch Statisten her für meinen Ausflug nach Düsseldorf. Also die beste KI ist ausgefallen, nehmt die vom letzten Jahr. Nehmt die? Die ist verbuggt. Ja, fuck it. Fuck it. Jetzt irgendwer was kommt rein da, aber ich habe noch nicht angezogen.
Das ist nicht mein Kind.
Rein da jetzt!
Geht da jetzt hin.
Es wird schon misstrauisch, dass hier keine Leute sind.
Das sind da aber schön leer.
Oh, Cappuccino trinken.
Das war unglaublich merkwürdig.
Das war ein Moment, den ich auch nie aufklären werde, können werde.
Das ist ja vorbei.
Der Moment ist verflogen.
Das war er.
Wahnsinn. Aber das war ganz merkwürdig, so ein ganz affektiertes, auch in meine Richtung gespieltes Ich weiß gar nicht, Moment, ganz seltsam, wirklich merkwürdig. Aber hat man manchmal so Momente, wo man an der Realität zweifelt. Ja, ja, vielleicht hatten die gerade einen Streit oder so und mussten dann so, oh, da ist jemand, oh, sind überspielt, schwierig. Aber dann denke ich mir auch, der Barkeeper wird ja bis jetzt eine riesen, unglaublich tolle Geschichte haben. Grosses Fragezeichen. Ja, ein Fragezeichen und eine tolle Geschichte zu erzählen. Und den einen kenne ich aus der O2-Werbung und der war hier, hieß aber anders und ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Hieß anders und hatte eine Abtreibung. Ich hatte auch wirklich so Momente, es gibt ja so Prämissenmomente, wo man denkt so, ja, wo führt das jetzt hin? Und ich hatte auch mit dem Zug gefahren, letzter Abteil, Junggesellenabschied, Bier, Party, laute Musik, dann dachte ich mir, fuck it, nächster Abteil, vorletzter Abteil, Junggesellinnenabschied. Zwei unterschiedliche Gruppen. Was möchte ich am wenigsten? Genau. Und ich dachte, das wird hier irgendwie wirklich so eine West Side Story Situation,
falls die aufeinandertreffen.
Und dann hast du so Gangfights zwischen diesen zwei extrem unangenehmen Gruppen Menschen,
die dann irgendwie so dazwischen kämpfen
und dann einfach mit so Schnapssachen
werfen. Das hatte ich auch mal,
Waggon, ich saß in einem
grossen Waggon, der war ganz leer,
als ich eingestiegen bin, auf dem Weg nach Berlin.
Dann, vorne, stiegen zu Hockey-Mannschaften.
Mit ganz langen Hockey-Spielerinnen.
Aber Feldhockey, nicht Eishockey.
Feldhockey. Unglaublich betrunken, laut Musik angemacht, Helene Fischer, atemlos durch die Nacht, schepperte durch den Waggon.
Vorne, ganz weit vorne, hat mich nicht gestört.
Dann stieg zu, ich sass in der Mitte, hinter mir Handball-Herrenmannschaft. Auch besoffen, kam auch hinzu, andere Seile des Waggons, auch ganz laut Bluetooth-Speaker angemacht, Helene Fischer, atemlos durch die Nacht. Aber leicht versetzt. Leicht versetzt, so wie so ein weirder Echo, Echo hat es eingesetzt. Dann in Bremen angekommen, ist er nach Hamburg dran, nach Bremen angekommen, stieg hinzu. Die Jugend des SV Werder Bremen, Kids, stiegen hinzu. Die sassen dann bei mir genau. Aber so sehr, denen war alles scheißegal, die sind vielleicht auch schon gut bezahlt, keine Ahnung, weil die Jugend von Werder Bremen. Und dann haben die sich auch so über die Sitze gelehnt und mich angeguckt. Also so unangenehm war das. Ja. Und dann von der einen Seite hatemlos durch die Nacht, von der anderen Seite hatemlos durch die Nacht. Und dann dachte ich mir irgendwann, dann standen wir, es war auf dem Weg zu Filmfights, ich weiß nämlich noch genau, und es war schon super spät, es ist eine Live-Sendung. Und es hat alles nicht hingehauen. Dann stand ich zwei Stunden irgendwo an einem Bahnhof in Bremen und ich habe schon wütende Nachrichten bekommen, weil ich zu spät bin und es eine Live-Sendung ist. Und dann war noch diese Situation, hat sich ja vor meinen Augen abgespielt. Und dann haben die irgendwann beschlossen, gegeneinander, weil die Jugend des SV Werder Rüben hatte, Fussbälle mit, miteinander Fussball zu spielen. What? Und dann haben die Handballerinnen, die Hockeyspielerinnen mit den Handballern Fussball gespielt und haben dann versucht, haben sich in eine Reihe gesetzt und haben dann versucht, möglichst viel Kopfball, Kopfball nacheinander hinzubekommen. Durch den ganzen Waggon haben die dann, und es hat sich so eine unglaubliche Szene, die haben sich da abgespielt, wirklich mit, dann haben die es auch zehnmal geschafft. Und irgendwann dachte ich mir, ich war grimmig, aber irgendwann habe ich das versucht abzulegen. Und habe einfach gedacht, ja, fuck it, ihr habt einfach Spaß. Ist doch euer gutes Recht. Ich bin gerade nur sauer, weil ich meine Termine habe, aber ist doch cool. Versucht ihr doch, irgendwie diesen Rekord aufzustellen, mit mit eurem Ballauf-Kopf-Ding zu köpfen.
Fand ich okay, dann war ich auch irgendwann, habe ich dann für die mitgeguckt, habe sie auch mitgefilmt.
Irgendwann steigt noch so ein klassisches Streicher-Quartett ein, irgendwie so ein Spiel dann Mozart.
Was passiert hier gerade? Ist hier los?
Aber nein, im Zug hat man still zu sein, egal was passiert.
Es war nicht der Ruhe-Wergon.
Ist egal.
Echt?
Ja, ich bin sowieso zu hart, was das angeht.
Ich wirklich schon nur, wenn Leute sich über den Gang hinweg unterhalten, sage ich schon Entschuldigung.
Können Sie Gespräche auf Ihre Seite des Zuges verlagern?
Können Sie bitte leise sein?
Na also.
Mit dem Blick auf?
Geht doch.
Mit dem Blick auf? Dann setze ich mich wieder.
Natürlich nicht, du kennst mich da auch, natürlich spreche ich nicht mit Leuten, aber ich stelle es mir vor. Ich weiß aber, was sagst du in dem Kino reden, dann rastest du schon auch mal aus, auf ne, innerlich, und dann kriegen die schon mal so ein, können wir bitte leise sein, nein, okay, zu hören, zumindest, aber das. Ja, das schon. Ja, ich kenne das auch von mir selbst.
Macht man schon.
Ach ja, im Zug hat man manchmal gute Begegnungen, das sind manchmal so unwirkliche Ergebnisse.
Aber gut, dass wir Zug fahren.
Die Deutsche Bahn übrigens hat unsere Vorwürfe gehört, dass sie nicht diejenigen sind, die, also dass diejenigen sein sollten, die laut im Klimastreit um die Ecke kommen und sagen sollten, hey, wir sind die Bahn, hey, Leute, fahrt doch mit uns, tun sie jetzt.
Yes! Die ICEs werden grün, grüne Striche. Coole Idee. Und generell tun sie viel für die Umwelt und haben diese tolle Kampagne, wie ich finde, wo sie zwei, hast du mir das nicht erzählt sogar, wo sie zwei verschiedene Bilder aus Deutschland und einem, meinetwegen dem Grand Canyon haben. Und dann haben sie also eine KI ausrechnen lassen, verschiedene coole Urlaubsorte auf der Welt, Beispiel Grand Canyon oder diese berühmte Amazonas-Schleife, und haben dann eine KI ausrechnen lassen, was die deutschen Pendants dazu wären. Und dann gibt es so einen geilen, die Saarschleife zum Beispiel haben sie dann neben die Amazonaschleife gelegt und so und dann gesagt, ihr könnt überall eure Ziele erreichen mit der Deutschen Bahn. Ganz tolle Kampagne, finde ich gut. Also, hört auf zu fliegen und packen die Bahn. Aber ganz kurz eine Sache, die so ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist, und zwar habe ich letztens gehört von unserem Verkehrsminister, der durchboxen wollte, dass man nicht mehr aktiv die Entschädigung für Verspätungen beantragen muss, sondern die automatisch kriegt. Mega. Und das ist die beste Idee aller Zeiten. Ich kenne mich nicht gut mit Politik aus, aber da denke ich, das ist die beste Idee, die jemals ein Politiker hatte. Niemand kann was dagegen haben, es hat nur Vorteile, die Bahn strengt sich mehr an, damit sie pünktlicher ist, damit sie nicht automatisch, weil 10% der Leute reichen das ein. Ich glaube, die Bahn hat Milliarden Verluste dadurch. Ja gut, dann sollen sie ihren Soldatenscheiss da mal einstellen. Das ist ein anderes Thema, aber so das und dann weißt du, jeder könnte automatisch das Geld zurückbekommen, alle sind besser drauf, wenn sie wissen, ah okay, ich kriege mein Geld zurück, nach einer Stunde Verspätung und die Bahn muss ich mehr ranhängen. Ich weiß nicht, was daraus geworden ist, das war von einem Jahr, habe ich es in der Zeitung gelesen, nichts mehr. Also, Verkehrsminister, falls du zuhörst, das Lobby-Ufo ist... Lass das mal nicht abkälten nur. So, Lobby-Ufo, wir müssen Lobby machen. Können wir machen. Wie wird man Lobbyist? Ich glaube, es ist der Ruf, habe ich mal gemacht, ich habe mal, in meinem Journalismusstudium
habe ich ja, glaube ich, Leute angerufen, um eine Antikorruptionsratifikation zu unterschreiben,
habe ich mal Druck gemacht im Bundestag.
Da war ich sozusagen Rechtslobbyist.
Und ist da was draus geworden?
Ja, wurde danach unterzeichnet.
Na, so haben wir es doch.
Gut, wunderbar, dann sagen wir Tschüss, perfekt Haken dran.
Bis nächste Woche, haut rein, macht's gut, wir sagen Tschüss und heben ab.